s est
ouverte l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au
Gouvernement la parole est à Monsieur
Dominique potier pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
socialiste madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Premier Ministre aujourd'hui au petit
matin une jeune femme une jeune
agricultrice a perdu la vie en AG pour
ses droits pour ses droits de vivre pour
ses droits à nous
nourrir son mari sa fille sont dans un
état de santé extrêmement grave
l'émotion est
vive aujourd'hui même si j'ai des
pudeurs à le dire je veux redire mon
attachement jerais vous dire simplement
que je suis paysan mais que nous pouvons
dire aujourd'hui que nous sommes tous
paysan
ce drame nous oblige il nous oblige à la
dignité au refus de la démagogie de
toutes les démagogies le groupe
socialiste à travers moi aujourd'hui
réaffirme trois choses très claires la
prospérité de l'agriculture française
s'est fait dans le cadre de l'Union
européenne et c'est par l'Union
européenne que nous retrouverons la
prospérité de l'agriculture
française la deuxième affirmation et que
nous refuserons toujours même si ce
n'est pas populaire d'opposer écologie
et économie car notre souveraineté
alimentaire dépend de la santé du
vivant et enfin 3è
affirmation je crois part
nous ne réussirons pas à gagner le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens au
prix de la destruction des emplois
industriels et agricoles mais par le
partage de la
valeur les normes devront toujours être
ajustées elles devront toujours être
appliqué avec humanité mais ne nous
trompons pas d'adversaires aujourd'hui
ce qui est la cause de la souffrance du
monde paysan ce sont les dérégulations
les concurrences déloyales les
expressions les plus néfastes du
libéralisme
nous formulons à cet instant cinq
propositions la première est
l'application immédiate de la loi igalim
mais la remise en cause de l'oligarchie
de la grande distribution la deuxième
est que toutes les transitions celle du
GNR celle des engrais des syst beaucoup
mon cher collègue je suis désolé vous
êtes déjà largement au-delà de votre
temps et il y a C propositions je pense
que ça va beaucoup trop déborder désolé
la parole est à monsieur Marc fenau
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
potier merci de votre question je
vourrais m'associer au mots que vous
avez eu pour cette jeune
agricultrice décédée ce matin aux
environs de 6h finalement et au fond ce
qu'elle faisait c'est qu'elle défendait
son métier son travail la dignité de son
métier et les difficultés les colères
qui s'expriment aujourd'hui partout en
France autour du monde agricole je vrais
dire que je partage les trois points que
vous avez évoqué le premier point c'est
d'abord d'un point de vue général je
pense qu'il faut qu'on sa dans ces
cas-là quand il y a cette colère et
quand il y a des drames humains comme
ceux qu'on vient de de vivre ne céder à
aucune démagogie et à aucune facilité la
facilité la démagogie c'est la pire des
choses quand il y a des crises comme
cell-là le premier le deuxième sujet que
je voulais évoquer vous avez raison nous
cherchons pas des bouqumèes où ils ne
sont pas toujours au niveau européen il
n'empêche que nous devons travailler
aussi au niveau européen à regarder
comment dans les normes dans la PAC dans
les accords internationaux dans les
clauses miroir on met bien en adéquation
les nécessaires transitions et en même
temps la volonté de souveraineté
deuxième élément il faut qu'on conjugue
transition et équilibre économique et
reconnaissons que depuis 20 ou 25 ans on
a mal conjugué ces choses-là alors vous
faites état de la concurrence extérieure
qui se crée à l'Union européenne mais
aussi la les les concurrences
intérieures qu'on a créé par des
surtranspositions et il faut en lucidité
se dire que il y a des surtranspositions
qui ont mis les agriculteurs français en
situation de risque et de déloyauté de
concurrence par rapport à leurs
collègues européens et ça aussi ça
nourrit une colère européenne que vous
ne voulez pas et que nous ne voulons pas
non plus et il me semble qu'on a besoin
de traviller puis vous avez parlé du
troisième point mais il y aura d'autres
questions c'est la question c'est la
question de la répartition de la valeur
nous avons posé sur la table la question
des galimes ce sommes le gouvernement
qui a a plusieurs reprises au travers de
différentes lois poser la la question de
la répartition de la valeur c'est ça sur
sur lequel nous devons être au
rendez-vous c'est le sens des contrôles
que nous allons exercer pour faire en
sorte que la lettre mais aussi que
l'esprit de la loi soit au rendez-vous
dans les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre un peu de silence la parole est
à Monsieur André Villier pour le groupe
horizon madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le profond malaise qui règne
en France affecte particulièrement le
monde agricole celles et ceux qui ont
choisi souvent paratavisme mais toujours
par passion de devenir paysan sont
profondément épris d'indépendance voire
de liberté or la réalité est tout autre
car confronté au dur conditions qui leur
sont réservé ils déchantent et crient
aujourd'hui leur désarrois à la société
entière les causes sont multiples et
anciennes au premier r en desquels se
trouve l'excès de taxes de normes et les
bas revenus le GNR c'est l'arbre qui
cache la forêt des exigences européennes
devenu insupportable car conditionné au
contrôle et à la crainte permanente de
l'erreur dont les les conséquences fin
financière sont vécu avec angoisse c'est
la corde qui tient le Pendu la dimension
environnementale et son cortège de
réglementation à l'exemple des MAEC dont
les DDT ont demandé ces jours derniers
aux agriculteurs de retirer une partie
des surfaces engagées pour limiter à
8000 € le montant de l'aide il aura
fallu deux lois d'itégalim pour tenter
d'améliorer le partage de la valeur la
montagne a accouché d'une souris c'est
un échec dont un signal faible a été le
passage à la trappe électorale des deux
rapporteurs la souveraineté alimentaire
ne peut pas accomodé d'un gaspillage
estimé à 20 % du tonnage des denrées
produites ce n'est pas acceptable 1 et5i
% des bénéficiaires de la PAC se
partagent 30 % de son enveloppe dont on
ne dit pas à nos concitoyens qu'elle est
constituée exclusivement d'argent
français qui transite par Bruxelles pour
nous revenir partiellement faisant de
notre pays un contributeur net au budget
de l'Union la célèbre formule
britannique des années 80 et d'actualité
want my money back des centaines
d'agriculteurs se voi rayer ces derniers
dernier jours du bénéfice des aides de
la PAC car cumulant parfois une retraite
de misère avec la poursuite de leur
activité agricole et c'est là une
décision non pas de l'administration
mais de la profession alors monsieur
Rousseau comment le dirigeant du groupe
avril et ces 6 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires peut-il être entendu
par les éleveurs charolet du Morvent
Monsieur le Premier Ministre venez
tremper votre première paire de botes
chez nous dans le morventp pays de V ban
et de la DME royale merci mon cher
collègue merci
beaucoup la
parole merci Mad la PR par monur
ministre de
l'Agriculture monsieur le député viler
j'ai nul intention de polémiquer mais je
veux vous dire une chose on a nul
intérêt d'opposer les agricultures entre
elles on a nul intérêt à opposer les
céréaliers les maréchés les viticulteurs
et les éleveurs beauvin ou les éleveurs
de porc ça n'est pas rendre service à
l'agriculture que d'opposer les
agriculteurs et la force de
l'agriculture française c'est sa
diversité alors oui nous avons des
problèmes vous avez raison monsieur
Villier nous avons essayé de résoudre un
certain nombre d'entre eux je réponds
d'abord à une question très précise sur
les mesures
agrienvironnementales nous avons
redéployé comme je l'avais annoncé au
mois de décembre un certain nombre de
crédits qui permettront de donner droit
à l'ensemble des demandes qui sont
faites par les agriculteurs ça avait été
évoqué par Thierry Benoît en Bretagne et
donc nous allons dans les jour prochains
donner droit aux demandes des
agriculteurs pourquoi parce que les
mesures agrienvironnementales ce sont
des mesures qui permettent d'encourager
les pratiques vertueuses et donc on a
besoin de travailler sur ces sujets-là
et puis vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon on a besoin on a collé
effement un devoir de lucidité et de
vérité ça fait 25 ans que
ça'accumule chacun
chacun monsieur le député chacun doit
prendre sa part je prends la mienne je
prends ma part de responsabilité mais le
cumul des normes sur les installation
classé le cumulle d'un certain nombre de
choses ils sont aujourd'hui sur la table
et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on doit aux
agriculteurs la vérité et donc j'espère
monsieur le député que nous
travaillerons collectivement pour enfin
résoudre C équation qui la surcharge de
normes qui pèse sur notre agriculture
c'est cellel qui pèse sur le moral des
agriculteurs il faut qu'on ait des
normes qui accompagnent qui encadre et
qui ne mettent pas sous la suspicion
permanente les agriculteurs c'est ça que
demand les agriculteurs c'est cette
dignité là qu' récl et ça fait 30 ans
que ça dure donc il va falloir qu'on
trouve les vois et moyens et j'espère
que nous serons debout dans cette salle
pour voter les textes et les amodiations
dont on a
[Applaudissements]
besoinoup
ministre la parole est à Madame Mathilde
IET pour le groupe la France
[Applaudissements]
insoumise merci madame la Présidente au
nom du groupe de la France insoumise
j'adresse nos condoléance et notre
soutien à la famille et aux proches de
l'agricultrice qui a tragiquement perdu
la vie ainsi qu'à son mari et sa fille
grièvement blessé ce
matin
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture
les agriculteurs sont des centaines à se
mobiliser pour défendre leurs droits
depuis des mois nous vous alertons sur
le malêtre et la grogne qui monte dans
les campagnes alors que l'inflation
alimentaire a atteint 14 % en 1 an les
prix payés aux agriculteurs ont baissé
de 10 %. entre les deux l'industrie
agroalimentaire a augmenté de 71 % son
taux de marge vous ne voyez pas le
problème les industriels se gavent alors
qu'en bout de la chaîînes les
agriculteurs et les consommateurs se
font asphyxier et tout ça avec la
complicité du gouvernement à votre
absence totale de proposition s'ajoutent
les problèmes qui relèvent de votre
responsabilité laactalis méprise ses
producteurs avec des prix honteux et vos
lois égal me laisse faire le budget des
Maek était mal calibré vous avez mis des
mois à réagir les agriculteurs
bioraavers une crise sans précédent vous
ne leur proposez que des miettes les a
pqu tardent à venir et les trésor ris se
dégradent que fait votre ministère nos
agriculteurs sont en compétition avec le
reste du monde et vous continuez à
signer les accords de libre
échange le monde agricole a toujours su
s'adapter et aujourd'hui encore il est
prêt il suffit de lui donner les moyens
sans mesures ambitieuses nos campagnes
risquent de finir aussi vide que la loi
que nous attendons depuis un an alors
réveillez-vous monsieur le ministre les
culteur disparaissent il y a un suicide
tous les de jours des centaines de
familles sont détruites chaque année à
cause de l'incertitude et de la
précarité des marchés agricoles ça
suffit vos discours creux et vos
reculades les paysans veulent vivre de
leur travail alors allez-vous enfin leur
garantir des prix rémunérateur par la
mise en place de prix plancher comme
nous l'avons proposé en novembre dernier
allez-vous soutenir notre proposition de
moratoire sur les accords de libre
échange je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur ministre de
l'Agriculture merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée iier dans des
moments aussi graves que ceux qu'on
traverse je pense que chacun doit faire
aussi son examen de conscience si je
peux me
permettre moi je vais vous dire ce que
j'entends des agriculteurs j'entends des
agriculteurs qu'ils en ont marre qu'à
longueur de plateau qu'à longueur de
reportage qu'à longueur d'expression on
vienent déigrer leur travail on vienne à
faire à croire que notre agriculture ne
serait pas la plus vertueuse la plus
qualitative la plus respectueuse de
l'environnement en France et à
l'internationale c'est ça qui leur fait
du mal aussi alors moi je prends mes
responsabilités mais vous je vous invite
à prendre les vôtres à prendre les
vôtres pour qu'on trouve le juste prix
et la rémunération et à prendre les
vôtres pour qu'enfin on leur dise qu'on
leur fait confiance et qu'on va les
accompagner dans les transitions pas
qu'on va les braquer et pas qu'on va
leur caler un modèle qui n'existe qui
n'existe que dans des utopies qui qui
n'existent nulle part sur la terre c'est
ça qu'on a à faire et c'est ça le droit
de vérité qu'on a vis-à-vis des
agriculteurs c'est ça qu'il réclame je
vous assure allez sur le terrain
écoutez-les
écoutez-les la colère qui
s'exprime la colère qui s'exprime c'est
une colère d'un sentiment de relégation
de mépris et de déclassement et c'est ça
contre lequel il faut vous
[Applaudissements]
plaît merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre allez un peu de silence s'il
vous
plaît alors s'il vous
plaît on va faire silence pour écouter
madame Marie pochon pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais d'abord réaffirmer toute ma
solidarité au proches de l'agricultrice
décédée ce matin en Ariège ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur le ministre partout dans notre
pays la révolte gronde une révolte qui
jusque là couvé loin de votre ministère
davantage habitué à recevoir les
capitaines d'industrie les agriculteurs
dénoncent un modèle qui ne fonctionne
pas et l'impossibilité de vivre de leur
métier les écologistes sont solidaires
de leur lutte pour vivre
dignement monsieur le ministre depuis 30
ans ceux qui nous gouvernent ont choisi
de placer notre modèle agricole sur la
voie de
l'industrialisation de la compétitivité
à outrance et du libre échange des régul
un peu de silence s'il vous plaît
laissez madame pochon poser sa question
et si vous souhaitez que le ministre y
réponde il faudrait d'abord qu'il puisse
l'entendre madame pochon continuez
résultat des inégalités immenses avec 20
% des fermes qui capte plus de la moitié
des aides européennes un agriculteur sur
5 qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
100000 fermes qui ont disparu en 10 an
on entend qu'il faudrait simplifier les
normes accélérer les procédures au nom
de la sarocinte compétitivité mais
est-ce qu'on veut vraiment être
compétitif avec les fermes usines
brésiliennes qui détruisent l'Amazonie
cessons cette mise en concurrence qui ne
fait que les affaires des grandes
multinationales qui fait disparaître les
paysans et détruit les conditions mêmes
de notre capacité à produire ici oui
chers collègues l'agriculture
l'agriculture n'est rien sans écologie
les agriculteurs le savent qui voient la
disparition des pollinisateurs et les
impacts des changements climatiques eux
qui s'adaptent t bien que mal à vos
injonctions contradictoir monsieur le
ministre vous ne pouvez pas demander en
même temps à nos agriculteurs
l'excellence sans aucun moyen tout en
leur imposant de produire à bas cou pour
être compétitif face au marché mondial
vous ne pouvez pas en même temps laisser
les prix agricoles s'effondrer et
refuser d'encadrer les surprofits de
l'agroindustrie qui ont vu l'an dernier
les profit leurs profit brut doubler de
3 à 7 milliards ce en quoi nous croyons
monsieur le ministre c'est en la
protection de l'excellence agricole
française et européenne celle qui
garantit des revenus celle qui nourrit
notre pays celle qui préserve notre
capacité à produire demain celle qui
nous rend fier monsieur le ministre
allez-vous enfin protéger et les
agriculteurs à ce libéralisme débridé
préférezvous continuer à garantir les
profits monstres de l'agrobusiness je
vous remercie la parole est à Mar
ministre de
l'Agriculture Messieurs les Députés
madame la présidente madame
pochon mal nommer les choses ou mal
nommer les problèmes c'est ajouter au
malheur du
monde il y a un certain nombre de
sujets nombre de sujets sur lesquels
vous avez raison c'est tout le sens de
l'engagement qui a été le NRE nous
sommes nous n'avons pas encore assez
abouti des mesures miroires et d'avoir
des accords internationaux qui respecte
des standards et des normes qui
correspondent plus à ceux des standards
et des normes européennes mais allons au
fait l'accord sur la le Mercosur qui s'y
oppose c'est la France l'accord sur
l'Australie qui s été opposé c'est la
France et donc il faut aussi juger sur
les actes et nous avons besoin aussi
parce qu'il faut le dire dans le
commerce international de faire vooir ce
qui est notre valeur notre excellence
notre capacité productive 50 % de nos
céréales sont exporté hors du du sol
français une grande partie de notre lait
une grande partie de nos fromages et
donc il faut pas renoncer à notre
capacité exportatrice c'est pour ça que
nous avons besoin de travailler sur
notre compétitivité et c'est pour ça que
nous avons besoin de travailler sur les
questions des normes pardon madame
pochon je suis d'accord avec vous sur
l'idée qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
conjuguer l'un et l'autre mais quand
vous demandez un agriculteur en terme
d'élevage d'agrandir son bâtiment parce
qu'il faut améliorer les conditions de
bien et qu'il a 50 procédures pour le
faire comment vous lui expliquez ça
quand vous demandez un éleveur un
éleveur quand vous demandez à un éleveur
et nous avons travaillé sur le sujet
c'est un point désaccord de conjuguer le
passotoralisme et en même temps de dire
on ne fait rien sur la population lou
vous avez un problème et nous nous avons
avancé sur le sujet et vous n'étiez pas
d'accord avec nous oui nous avons besoin
de réviser le statut de l'espèce et
c'est ce que nous avons fait puis qu'il
y aura une décision européenne et c'est
ça que nous avons besoin de faire de ne
pas être aveugle au problèm pour pouvoir
conjuguer l'écologie et les questions de
souveraineté sinon nous n'y arriverons
pas c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de bien
nommer les choses et de bien apporter
les réponses je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Travert pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais au nom des
députés du groupe Renaissance je veux
dire notre émotion devant le drame qui
est survenu ce matin en Arriège et nos
pensées vont vers la famille et tous les
agriculteurs de laffire
France Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre de
alimentaire la France est une grande
nation agricole la France est reconnue
pour la qualité et la durabilité de son
agriculture et de ses systèmes les
agriculteurs font partie de l'identité
de notre pays et détiennent une partie
de la solution aux défis qui nous font
face soyez assuré Monsieur le Ministre
que la représentation nationale est
fière de ses agriculteurs de leur
engagement et de leur courage en Europe
l'Allemagne la Roumanie les Pays-Bas
connaissent des manifestations d'ampleur
sur la taxe sur les carburants la
diminution des cheptels notamment en
France le mouvement de colère des
agriculteurs nous rappelle combien le
dialogue et la recherche de solutions
pérennes doivent être au cœur de nos
priorités à travers ces mouvements les
producteurs veulent nous partager un
sentiment mêlé de désespérance et de
déclassement celui aussi d'être
emprisonné dans un système fait
d'injonction contradictoire tant en
France qu'au niveau européen les
agriculteurs sont à la fois victimes des
changements climatiques mais ils en sont
aussi la solution comme acteur majeur de
la transition dont ils sont convaincus
et engager aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre il nous demande de lever les
freins sur la compétitivité de respecter
les accords passés dans la loi égalime
ils n'accepent plus d'être entravés dans
leur travail quotidien avec des
contraintes franco-françaises qui les
mettent dans l'impasse alors que parfois
leurs voisins européens n'y sont pas
soumis ces revendications monsieur le
ministre elles sont légitimes c'est le
sens du vote de la résolution pour
lutter contre les surtranspositions que
j'avais déposé et que nous avons adopté
à une très large majorité en ma dernier
c'est un message de confiance que nous
devons envoyer à l'agriculture française
car les agriculteurs
merci la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le ministre Stéphane Travert
tout à l'heure à Pamier dans
l'Arriège une femme une mère de famille
une agricultrice a perdu la vie son mari
et sa fille sont gravement blessés à
l'heure où nous nous parlons c'est une
profession qui est en deuil c'est toute
notre ruralité qui pleure une famille
mais ce drame raésonne en chacune et en
chacun d'entre nous et c'est tout un
pays qui est touché je veux à nouveau au
nom du gouvernement et en votre nom à
tous rendre hommage à cette famille leur
dire notre solidarité et notre
soutien
encore ce weekend je rencontrais des
agriculteurs dans le rhô j'étais hier
avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture avec la FNSEA les jeunes
agriculteurs et je rencontrerai
l'ensemble des organisations
représentatives de nos agriculteurs
aujourd'hui et dans les jours à venir
parler avec les agriculteurs c'est
d'abord parler de passion celle de leur
métier celle de notre terre celle de
leur bête c'est parler de
transmission de leur volonté de faire
connaître et de partager leur vocation
c'est parler d'engagement d'une France
qui se lève aux aurores chaque jour qui
travaille qui ne demande que les moyens
de pouvoir bien faire son métier et de
la reconnaissance c'est aussi parler
d'une crainte celle de la disparition de
notre mod de la perte de la qualité de
l'absence de relève c'est enfin
comprendre une blessure celle de femmes
et d'hommes qui donne tout pour notre
terre tout pour nos bêtes et qui se
trouve sans cesse dénigré caricaturé
acculé et je le dis avec le plus grand
calme mais aussi avec la plus grande
détermination
parfois vos larmes pour nos agriculteurs
ressemblent à des larmes de crocodiles
vraiment parce que la
réalité c'est qu'à chaque fois que nos
agriculteurs que nos éleveurs familiaux
ont un projet d'extension de leur
élevage qui s'y oppose vos amis avec
votre soutien à chaque fois qu'un projet
est lancé dans notre pays sur une
retenue d'eau pour lutter contre la
sécheresse sur des investissements pour
nos exploitations ce sont vos amis qui
s'y opposent à chaque problème répondz
par une norme à chaque difficulté vous
répondez plutôt en général en pointant
du Doig nos
agriculteurs je le dis avec le plus
grand calme quand certains discours
portés sur nos agriculteurs les
présentent comme des bandits comme des
pollueurs de notair comme des
tortionnaires de leurs animaux on aerait
aussi entendre vos indignations et votre
défense du modèle
agricole
parler avec nos agriculteurs c'est
évidemment parler avec des femmes des
hommes qui sont évidemment dans
l'angoisse et je vais y revenir mais
c'est aussi parler avec des femmes et
des hommes lucides lucide sur
l'importance de l'Union européenne et ça
a été redit par le ministre Marc fen
pour les aides de la Pâque pour nos
capacités d'export et donc je le dis il
y a aussi une lucidité face à ceux qui
butinent de colère en colère en donnant
le sentiment qu'on pourrait sortir de
l'Union
européenne votre président est
aujourd'hui avec les pêcheurs on y
reviendra tout à l'heure dans des
questions aujourd'hui on en parle
beaucoup il y a des caméras le 26
décembre quand les pêcheurs en colère
angoissés étaient en train de créer leur
revendication on n'a pas vu monsieur
Bardella on a vu madame Lisiane mteyer
député de cette majorité qui elle
n'était pas en vacances qui était sur le
terrain avec
eux en échangeant avec les représentants
de nos
agriculteurs nous avons eu l'occasion de
revenir sur les grands sujets et vous
l'avez fait monsieur Stéphane Travert il
y a des enjeux de très court terme sur
le versement des aides qui sont d à nos
agriculteurs face aux catastrophes qui
sont survenues face aux maladies et nous
y sommes mobilisés avec le ministre Marc
F il y a l'enjeu des négociations
commerciales et nous aurons l'occasion
d'ici la fin de semaine Bruno Le Maire a
d'ors et déjà fait des annonces sur les
contrôles d'annoncer des initiatives en
la matière la loi égalime doit être
respectée on ne renégocie pas les
matières premières
agricoles nous avancerons également sur
la question des normes et de la
simplification nous avons engagé un
travail avec les représentants des
agriculteurs qui nous feront remonter
toutes les propositions nous regarderons
toutes les propositions et nous
prendrons toutes les mesures utiles et
nécessaires dans le cadre du projet loi
porté par le ministre de l'Agriculture
oui nous allons avancer sans tabou sans
faux semblant avec une détermination et
avec la mobilisation de cette majorité
qui elle n'a jamais fait défaut à nos
agriculteurs je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Grégoire de fournass pour rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au Premier ministre
je voudrais commencer par rendre homage
agricultce tué ce matin par un chaufard
lors d'une manifestation d'
d'agriculteur dans la
[Applaudissements]
riège monsieur le Premier
ministre semain les agriculteurs
manifestent leur ralbol de votre
politique totalement incohérente qui
consiste à leur imposer toujours plus de
normes tout en les mettant en
concurrence avec la terre entière nous
vous alertons depuis des mois sur cette
France rurale et du travail qui n'en
peut plus et malgré nos mises en garde
vous avez vous avez voté le traité de
libre échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
qui va faire venir des milliers de
tonnes de viande et de lait et dont la
production ne respecte aucune des normes
imposées à nos agriculteurs vous
continuez à soutenir tout for cette
feuille de route européenne d'une d'une
écologie punitive et de décroissance
agricole dictée par les pires
écologistes d'extrême gauche au mois de
décembre et malgré notre ferme
opposition Vous avez fait voter une
augmentation de la fiscalité sur le GN
alors que l'agriculture française est
déjà asphyxiée par les charges alors que
nos agriculteurs sont à l'agonie vous
essayez de gagner du temps par vos
concertations stériles et la promesse
d'une d'une loi d'orientation agricole
dont la acité ne réglera aucun des
problèmes des agriculteurs Monsieur le
Premier Ministre cessez votre enfumage
et répondez à ces trois questions
essentielles allez-vous revenir sur
l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur le
GNR allez-vous dénoncer le traité de
libre échange avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
et abandonner les négociations avec le
mercosour allez-vous mettre fin à
l'écologie punitive et à la stratégie
FEM tout for que vous avez voté au
Parlement européen avec les écologistes
répondez à ces trois questions tout le
reste n'est que bavardage
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Marc F ministre de
l'Agriculture merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député de fournasse
on n'est jamais surpris avec vous vous
n'êtes jamais en retard d'une démagogie
ou d'une
récupération alors oui nous avons des
problèmes oui nous avons besoin que au
travers des normes le Premier ministre
vient de le dire au travers de la
simplification travers de la
compétitivité nous travaillons pour les
agriculteurs vous êtes un un élu qui
connaît son territoire vous êtes un élu
de Gironde les viticulteurs de Gironde
ils ont besoin de quoi ils ont besoin de
compétitivité ils ont besoin qu'on les
accompagne on l'a fait par la
distillation en 2023 200 million d'euros
ils ont besoin vous savez quoi ils ont
besoin d'échanges
commerciaux parce que si le bordeau ne
s'exporte pas vous m'expliquerez comment
il continuera à y avoir une viticulture
en
Gironde et donc ils ont besoin qu'on
leur dise les grands enjeux de les
accompagner dans la compétitivité et pas
dans les les enfermés dans l'autarciie
qui au fond les condamnent à disparaître
c'est ça sur lequel on a besoin de
travailler enfin je veux répondre sur je
veux répondre sur la question du GNR
nous avons mis en place avec Bruno LEM
un mécanisme qui était un mécanisme de
baisse de l'avantage fiscal 70 millions
sur 1 milliard 3 avec des compensations
fiscales qui permettent de compenser à
l'euro l'euro d'un point de vue global
ces compensations il s'avère laissez-moi
finir il s'avère et c'est ce que disent
aussi les manifestants que sur les
territoires ça ne se répartit pas
forcément de façon homogène je l'ai dit
je l'ai dit mais je l'ai dit et donc on
est en train de travailler de regarder
avec les organisations professionnelles
comment les choses peuvent s'équilibrer
et comment on peut à la fois avoir une
trajectoire sur la fiscalité et en même
temps avoir une trajectoire qui soit
bien répartie sur l'ensemble des
territoires et qui corresponde à
l'ensemble des besoins des agriculteurs
c'est ça ce qu'il faut monsieur de
fournass c'est leur dire la vérité c'est
répondre à leur problème je prends ma
part des choses je prends ma part et
chacun doit prendre sa part des choses
qui n'ont pas été faites mais il me
semble qu'on a besoin d'accélérer et si
vous pouviez sortir de la démagogie
peut-être qu'on avancerai au service de
l'agriculture je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre vous nêes
pas agriculteur moi je suis viticulteur
et mon père qui a 62 ans et qui est
aussi viticulteur ne se paye plus depuis
plus d'un an alors arrêtez avec vos vos
accusations le vide sidéral de votre
réponse est laaveu de votre impuissance
l'agriculture française est au bord du
goufre c'est
la parole est à Monsieur Julien div pour
le groupe les républicains merciadame la
présidente les républicains s'associent
à la douleur du monde agricole et
adressent leur condance à la famille de
d'Alexandra Monsieur le Premier Ministre
leur fin F sera notre fin faim la colère
des agriculteurs qui éclate dans tout le
pays frle le point de non retour ne
soyez pas étonnés c'est la conséquence
des promesses tombées au champs
d'honneur qui ont fini de les exaspérer
votre majorité leur promet des lois pour
leur simplifier la vie pendant qu'au
Parlement européen vous votez en
randonion la décroissance derrière
monsieur campfin quelle imposture en
reportant sans cesse les réponses
attendues vous participez au déclin
deagriculture française ce n donc pas
simplement un projet de loi que vous
retardez mais l'avenir même de notre
agriculture et de notre souveraineté
alimentaire juillet automne décembre
janvier et finalement la LOA est
désormais annoncée après le salon
d'agriculture il y a encore quelques
jours vous étiez donc prêt à présenter
au Conseil des ministres un texte bref
moins 10 an pour tenter d'acheter la
paix sociale agricole vous nous menez en
bateau les surtranspositions de normes
les contraintes sont toujours plus
pressentes les contrôles toujours plus
inquisiteurs pendant qu'à côté nous
accueillons des produits étrangers
suivant des règles que nous ne tlerons
pas chez nous ne soyez pas plus
royaliste que le roi sur les normes
agricoles vous interdisez certains
produits phytosanitaires mais vous ne
donnez que des miettes à la recherche
d'Alternativ vous n'assumez pas les
choix courageux des nouvelles technique
de sélection variétale pour répondre aux
enjeux environnementaux les agriculteurs
vous réclament des prix vous bricollez
une de loi sur les négociations
commerciales sans effet cette Assemblée
nationale vote à l'unanimité la réforme
du système des retraites agricoles vous
mettez 12 mois à nous sortir un scénario
d'entrée en vigueur réveillez-vous les
agriculteurs n'ont pas à choisir entre
les adistes bourgeois qui les
zigouillent et le citadin Bardella la
opportuniste qui découvre les fermes
avec les républicains nous faisons un
seul choix leur faire confiance leur
permettre de vivre d'être bien rémunéré
le diagnostic est posé voici le remè gel
de la taxe génr abrogation des
surtransposition
maise des charges sociales
investissement et autorisation pour le
stockage de l'eau révision des règles de
négociation alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ques sont vos solutions
aujourd'hui maintenant avec quel moyen
il mérite des réponses et non des sans
merci beaucoup mon cher cèg la parole
est à
Monsieur ministre de l'Agriculture merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés vous bien connaissz bienes
sujets je vais essayer de répondre sur
un nombre de points prier point sur les
sujets des négociations commercial je ne
connais pas un agriculteur ou une
organisation professionnelle qui
voudrait qu'on revienne sur la loi Galim
il nous demande d'aller plus loin il
nous demande de vérifier d'aller au
contrôle donc ne dites pas que cette loi
a été inutile cette loi elle a été un
premier pas sur la
rémunération cette loi elle est et on a
besoin que dans il a parlé des
négociations commerciales je crois me
semble que ça fait partie des GAL mais
donc on a besoin d'aller plus loin de
faire en sorte que la contractualisation
soit respectée de faire en sorte
d'inciter un certain nombre de filière à
rentrer dans Galim c'est ça qu'on a
besoin de faire on a besoin d'y
travailler ensemble deuxème est
l'élément sur la loi d'orientation nous
avions un texte effectivement centré sur
la question du renouvellement des
générations avec des moyens importants
qui ont été d'ailleurs votés
budgétairement j'en dirai un mot juste
après il nous semble que dans le moment
qu'on traverse on a besoin d'accélérer
sur un certain nombre de procédures qui
était d'ailleurs et vous le savez inclus
dans le pacte et donc on a besoin s'il y
a besoin d'éléments législatifs de le
faire et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
prendre ce temps-là pour répondre
concrètement vous avez raison au demande
qui sont celles des agriculteurs et puis
nous avons un sujet européen monsieur le
député div c'est moi qui ai pris
l'initiative au nom de la France d'une
demande de de suppression de la
dérogation de la l'affaire des jacher
des 4 % de jacher pour faire en sorte
que dans ce monde où nous importons en
Europe 40 millions de tonnes de céréales
on arrête de mettre en jacher et en
inculture un certain nombre de terres
c'est la France qui a été rejointe par
22 pays maintenant on attend de la
commission qu'elle réponde et c'est le
combat que nous continuons à mener c'est
la France et c'est les délégations
françaises y compris de renaissance qui
a mené des négociations pour faire en
sorte que le texte sur la restauration
de la nature n'aboutissent pas à la mise
sous cloche de la nature alors oui il y
a des enjeux oui il y a des batailles à
mener oui il y à faire en sorte que que
dans le Green Deal on Vienne bien
conjuguer les transitions parce que vous
le savez comme moi monsieur le député il
y a besoin de transition il y a des
secteurs entiers de l'agriculture en
zone intermédiaire en particulier qui
sont en grande difficulté du fait du
dérèglement climatique mais on a besoin
de le conjuguer avec la souveraineté et
c'est ça et c'est ce combat là qu'il
faut continuer à mener y compris au
niveau
européen je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Mathieu Lefèvre pour le
comprenaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique monsieur le
ministre depuis 2017 sous l'autorité du
Président de la République vous incarnez
une politique économique qui libère
l'activité et protège les Français des
crises que nous avons connu face à la
crise sanitaire vous étiez là face à la
crise énergétique vous étiez là grâce au
bouclier énergétique l'État a pris en
charge la moitié de la facture des
Français grâce à cette politique qu' N a
soutenu la majorité et qu'elle seule la
facture d'électricité des Français est
parmi les plus basses
d'Europe alors aujourd'hui les
oppositions s'indignent de la sortie des
dispositifs de crise certains par pure
hypocrisie et d'autres par paresse
intellectuelle à l'extrême droite on
déplore les causes les conséquences des
causes qu'on chérit à l'extrême droite
qui a soutenu l'agresseur russe en
Ukraine grand responsable grand
responsable de la hausse des prix de
l'électricité et à l'extrême gauche on
voudrait se priver des recettes qui
permettent de financer le chèque énergie
pour les plus modestes et qui permettent
également le développement des énergies
renouvelables extrême gauche et extrême
droite joignent le leur voix pour
implorer le retour du bouclier
énergétique contre lequel ils ont voté
alors mes chers
collègues si nous avions attendu ces
oppositions les factures des Français
auraient plus que doublé ces trois
dernières années les Français doiv le
savoir et oui parce que autour de
Gabriel nous formons une majorité
responsable une
majorité une majorité qui refuse le
déclassement qui refuse l'endettement
une majorité qui sait que la dette
d'aujourd'hui ce sont les impôts de
demain pour l'ensemble de ces raisons
nous soutenons que la sortie de crise
signifie sortie des dispositifs de crise
ma question monsieur le ministre est
donc de savoir comment le gouvernement
endré pour continuer à faire en sorte
que les prix de l'électricité soi plus B
en France
cailleur merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre en charge de
l'économie des finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Le
Fèvre
silence quand les prix de l'électricité
ont explosé monsieur le député
Lefèvre cette majorité a mis en
place un bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité qui nous a permis de
prendre en charge la moitié des factures
d'électricité de nos compatriotes ce
bouclier vous avez voté contre vous avez
voté contre également vous n'avez aucune
leçon de pouvoir d'achat à nous donner
pour la protection de nos
compatriotes nous avons toujours indiqué
avec le Premier ministre avec le
président de la République que nous
sortirions progressivement de ce
bouclier tarifaire il y avait une taxe
intérieure sur la consommation finale
d'électricité était à 32 € le MWh avant
la crise nous l'avons ramené à 1 €
pendant la crise nous la faisons
progressivement remonté à 21 € en
dessous de ce qu'elle était avant la
crise pour sortir
progressivement pour continuer à
financer le chèque énergie des plus
modestes les 6 millions de ménages qui
vont toucher 150 € pour éviter la
précarité énergétique pour financer les
énergies renouvelables et pour faire en
sorte que nos compatriotes des
départements d'outremer et de Corse ne
payent pas leur électricité plus chère
c'est à la fois juste et responsable ça
définit bien notre majorité enfin je
rappelle que si nous voulons la
prochaine fois protéger nos compatriotes
aussi bien que nous l'avons fait pendant
la crise du covid et pendant la crise
inflationniste il faut savoir sortir
définitivement du quoi qu'il en coûte ça
aussi c'est une question de justice et
une question de responsabilité c'est le
sens de la décision que nous avons prise
sur les tarifs
d'électricité je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Sébastien Jumel pour le groupe
GDR je le dis avec
gravité ils veulent nourrir pas mourir
avec gravité au moment où un dramatique
accident de la route a endeuillé une
famille d'agriculteurs en Ariège le
groupe GDR s'associa à l'hommage à cette
famille qui manifestait simplement pour
sa dignité ils veulent nourrir pas
mourir asphyés par des choix politiques
libéraux technocratique qui à Bruxelles
comme à Paris tourne le dos à la terre
et à la mer nourricière au sortir du
confinement le président promettait de
revenir aux fondamentaux à la
souveraineté alimentaire du pays mais le
fossé n'a jamais été aussi grand entre
les promesses de l'exécutif et la
réalité quotidienne des artisans de
notre souveraineté alimentaire pêcheurs
et agriculteurs lesté de bouler notre
agriculture comme notre pêche vive des
crise majeure tout le démontre barrage
sur les routes fermeture d'atelierers
laitiers chez moi en Normandie indignité
des négociations commerciales qui
réservent aux producteurs le sort des
citrons pressés accord de libre échange
qui fonde sur notre agriculture comme le
loup sur l'agneau loi d'orientation
agricole vide et sans arrêt repoussé à
la pêche même tempête 450 bateaux
assignés à quai autour du Golfe de
gastcogne brexit plan de sortie de
flotte envoler des prix du gazoil avec
des aides taries pour les les armements
à plusieurs navires avalange de
contraintes réglementaires et pour
couronner le tout baisse des quotas en
Normandie Bretagne haute-france partout
la filière est menacée alors que nous
n'avons même pas de ministre de plein
exercice et pendant ce temps vous
supprimez la détaxe sur le gazouile
Agricole vous laissez filer les quotas
de notre pêche artisanale vous ajoutez
10 % d'électricité pour tout le monde
monsieur Marc fenau pas de Pipo pas de
blabla pas de posture les réponses vous
les devez à ceux qui nourrissent la
France et vous devez les
actes merci mon cher collègue la parole
est à Monsieur Mar ministre de
l'Agriculture merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député jumell vous
êtes à la fois une terre agricole et une
terre de pêcheur et je pas de blabla et
je vais vous dire exactement ce qu'on
essaie de faire depuis des années avec
un certain nombre de résultats qui sont
tangibles j'ai parlé tout à l'heure des
lois égalim elles ont permis de reposer
la question de la juste rémunération je
suis sûr que nous pourrons partager
ensemble la nécessité que nous bâtions
en brèche tous ceux qui viennent nous
expliquer à longueur de plateau télé
dision que le juste prix c'est le prix
le plus bas l'agriculture elle a un coût
et comme elle a un coût elle doit
trouver son prix et c'est notre
responsabilité de faire appliquer les
lois qui ont été votées dans dans les
assemblées et c'est notre responsabilité
aussi collectivement de faire en sorte
que dans le débat on vienne à chaque
fois dire dans le débat inflation oui
mais quelle est la rémunération des
agriculteurs ou des pêcheurs premier
élément deuxème élément les agriculteurs
ils ont besoin qu'on les accompagne dans
les transitions le budget de
l'agriculture cette année c'est 1,2
milliard d'euros de plus plus et pour
répondre d'ailleurs à la question de
Monsieur div je crois c'est 250 millions
pour retrouver des alternatives aux
produits phytosanitaires ça c'est du
concret pardon je vous le dire et ça va
permettre aux agriculteurs de pouvoir
anticiper les éléments des éléments de
transition et puis troisème élément
c'est sur les négociation mais nous
allons discuter avec les les filières
laitières comme je l'ai fait depuis que
je suis arrivé à mon ministère et mon
prédécesseur aussi pour faire en sorte
que chacun prenne ses responsabilités
dans le temps qui reste de négociation
et vous pouvez compter sur nous c'est ce
qu'on a fait d'ailleurs l'an dernier
permettez moi de vous le dire et puis je
voudrais dire un mot des accords
internationaux vous êtes une terre que
vous le vouliez ou non laitièr et donc
une terre qui exporte des produits
laitiers et donc on a besoin donc on a
besoin de renforcer la compétitivité de
cette filière de favoriser
l'installation d'alléger un certain
nombre de normes qui viennent plutôt
freiner qu'entrav en fait vous disiez
les agriculteurs veulent nous nourrir et
pas mourir vous avez raison ils veulent
du respect et pas du dénigrement ils
veulent de la confiance et pas de la
défiance ils veulent des prix
rémunérateurs et pas la course à
l'échalote entre la grande distribution
pour le prix le plus bas et tout ça nous
pouvons le partager et c'est les textes
et les éléments que le premier ministre
présentera dans les jours qui viennent
pour avancer concrètement sur ces sujets
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Martine
Froger pour le
groupe merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture je m'adresse à
vous en tant que député de l'Arriège une
Arriège meurtrie en ce jour sombre ce
matin à Pamier alexandra jeune
agricultrice de 35 ans a été fauchée
alors qu'elle manifestait pacifiquement
avec sa famille et les agriculteurs
ariégeois ils étaient présents sur ce
barrage pour exprimer leur colère et
leur incompréhension contre un système
qui abandonne nos paysans son mari et sa
fille sont très grièvement blessés
toutes mes pensées vont à eux et
j'adresse toutes mes condoléances à la
famille aux proches et à l'ensemble du
monde paysan qui est illé aujourd'hui
j'associe j'associe mon collègue député
de la riège Laurent panifous qui est
actuellement en place au côté des
agriculteurs cette terrible nouvelle
nous bouleverse et tous ici nous avons à
y répondre depuis plusieurs mois la
colère des agriculteurs éclate au grand
jour ce n'est pas une colère épisodique
mais le résultat d'années de concion de
vie inacceptable nos agriculteurs se
sentent abandonnés
stigmatisés caturé malaimé leur colère
est multifactorielle augmentation des
matières pr premières et de l'énergie
augmentation de la taxe sur le GNR des
tâches administratives toujours plus
contraignantes sans être accompagné les
retards des versements de la PAC sont
devenus la règle en Arriège les demandes
d'aide au titre de l'échorégime ont été
faites depuis plus de de mois mais les
versements n'interviennent toujours pas
malgré les promesses les lois égalimes 1
et 2 ne sont toujours pas appliquées
encore faut-il rappeler que enfin
faut-il rappeler que certains
travaillent jusqu'à 80 heur par semaine
sans disposer pour autant de revenus
décent qui d'autre accepterait de
travailler dans ces conditions alors
monsieur le ministre de l'Agriculture je
vous le demande solennellement combien
d'autres DRAM suicide ou accident
faudra-t-il pour qu'enfin nos
agricultures soient entendues monsieur
le ministre de de l'agriculture prenez
la mesure du désarroi du découragement
et de la colère du monde agricole venez
les rencontrer
il n'est plus temps d'attendre
l'agriculture doit désormaisêt déclaré
priorité nationale beauoup merci
beaucoup ma chers collègu la parole est
à Marc F ministre de
l'Agriculture merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Froger je
voudrais vous remercier de votre
question et de la dignité de votre
question parce qu'au fond les problèmes
que vous posez dans le drame que vous
avez vécu dans la dans la rèche son réel
je voudrais d'abord m'incliner dans la
mémoire de cette jeune agricultrice elle
avait 37 ans elle défendait son métier
pacifiquement sur un endroit où il
s'était organisé l'enquête et la justice
diront ce qu'il en est de cette
manifestement de ce qui est cet accident
mais je voudrais m'associer à la fois la
peine de sa famille à la peine des
agriculteurs de larriège et à la peine
de toute la nation face à ce qui a un
drame inconcevable quand on veut
défendre son métier deuxème élément de
de réponse je me rendrai dans les
minutes qui viennent je pars en Arriège
pour aller à la rencontre et témoigner
dans ce moment de deuil et d'émotion de
la du soutien de la nation et du soutien
du gouvernement du premier ministre du
président de la République dans ce
territoire endeuiller qui reconnaît de
nombreuses difficultés je me souviens
d'un déplacement que j'ai fait vous
étiez à mes côtés nous avions évoqué un
certain nombre de sujets je pense en
particulier en Arriège au sujet de la
prédation qui nourrit beaucoup de
querell et beaucoup d'incompréhension
dans le monde agricole et sur lequel il
faudra bien qu'un jour ou l'autre comme
on l'a fait sur le loup on puisse
avancer et donc nous serons à vos côtés
sur ces sujet là vous avez raison ils
ont besoin de
reconnaissance ils ont besoin que dans
des territoires comme ceux là on puisse
reconnaître les spécificités les
handicaps particuliers qu'ils
connaissent soit d'accès à l'eau soit
les handicaps l aux zones de montagne
ils ont besoin qu'on reconnaisse ces
systèmes de petites exploitations de
policulture élevage qui ont besoin de se
diversifier mais qui ont besoin d'accès
à l'eau pour un certain nombre d'entau
et qui ont besoin d'être accompagnés
dans les transitions c'est le sens
d'ailleurs des fonds de transition que
nous mettons sur la table et donc nous
avons je me rendrai donc en arrière je
me rendrai prochainement aussi en
Occitanie pour d'autres sujets c'est une
région qui est particulièrement en
souffrance en tout cas je vais m'y
rendre et cet après-midi et le travail
que nous ferons dans les semaines
suivantes en n'oubliant pas cette jeune
femme et en oubliant pas le combat
qu'elle menait parce que c'est notre
combat à tous je vous remercie monsieur
le
ministre la parole est à présent à
Madame anneelore babo pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la Présidente
tout d'abord comme nos collègues l'ont
fait le groupe démocrate a une pensée
émue pour la jeune agricultrice décédée
ce matin pour son conjoint et sa fille
qui sont dans un état grave nous
adressons toutes nos pensées à leurs
proches
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie et des finances Bruno Le
Maire et concerne la question des
négociations commerciales qui impactent
directement nos
agriculteurs monsieur le ministre comme
vous le savez il nous reste 7 jours 7
jours pour aboutir aux négociations
commerciales entre les distributeurs et
les industriels c'est donc le moment
d'agir monsieur le ministre d'être
auprès de nos entreprises de nos
agriculteurs et de contrôler massivement
nos distributeurs et certains
industriels qui régulièrement ne
respectent pas la
loi nos agriculteurs sonnent l'alarme
ils sont les victimes d'un modèle
économique qui les dessert porté par nos
grands distributeurs ils sont victimes
d'une course au prix le plus bas d'un
partage de la valeur qui n'est pas
équitable or un agriculteur sur 5 vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté 5 € de l'heure
c'est ce que gagne en moyenne un
agriculteur exploitant si nous voulons à
l'avenir manger français la question du
revenu agricole est centrale nous avons
un patrimoine à conserver et
l'agriculture la plus durable du monde
si la transition agroécologique doit se
mener activement elle atteint coût les
agriculteurs ne doivent plus être la
variable
d'ajustement la loi igalim a pour
objectif de sanctuiriser les matières
premières agricoles si ces dernières
années nous avons pu constater des
améliorations dans les échanges cette
année dans une grande partie des
négociations ce n'est pas le
cas alors monsieur le ministre en
novembre dernier vous aviez annoncé une
mission gouvernementale afin de
travailler en profondeur le sujet dans
l'immédiat j'aimerais savoir quelles
actions vous comptez mettre en place
pour répondre à la souffrance de nos
agriculteurs je vous
remerci je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique merci madame la présidente
madame la députée elord babo
la loi égalime toute la loi égalime doit
être intégralement et rigoureusement
respectée et nous y veillerons avec le
ministre de l'Agriculture et avec le
Premier ministre nous veillons au
respect de la loi égalim sur le volet
aval de cette loi qui prévoit que entre
les producteurs et les industriels
transformateurs un certain nombre de
Claus doit figurer dans les contrats je
suis d'autant plus attaché que lorsque
j'étais ministre de l'Agriculture j'ai
mis en place ces contrats pour protéger
le revenu des producteurs agricoles il y
a une clause de révision des prix il
doit y avoir une clause de révision des
prix dans chaque contrat il y a une
clause de transparence il doit y avoir
une clause de transparence dans chaque
contrat enfin un prix est un prix quand
un industriel s engagé auprès d'un
producteur de lait à le rémunérer 390 €
la tonne de lait il ne doit pas le payer
385 ou 380 il doit rigoureusement
respecter les termes du contrat nous
doublerons les contô ô sur les
transformateurs industriels de 120
l'année dernière à 240 en 2024 en
augmentant le nombre d'agents de la
DGCCRF pour assurer le bon contrôle du
respect des contrats entre industriel
transformateurs et
producteurs en aval même chose nous
avons une disposition qui a été volue
par l'intégralité des députés de cet
hémicycle qui est une clause dite de
saclage du revenu des agriculteurs qui
prévoit que lorsqu'il y a une variation
du prix du produit dans la grande
distribution le revenu des agriculteurs
ne doit pas être la variable
d'ajustement de cette variation de prix
nous veillerons à ce que cette clause de
saclage soit rigoureusement et
strictement respectée par l'intégralité
des producteurs là aussi les
distributeurs là aussi nous
multiplierons les contrôles nécessaires
et nous prononcerons toutes les
sanctions exemplaires pour faire
respecter la loi égalime par les
distributeurs comme par les industriels
pour protéger le revenu des producteurs
je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Kevin
pffer pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie ça y
est vous avez eu la lourde charge
d'annoncer au 20H la première grande
mesure du gouvernement de Gabriel hatal
vous qui nous promettiez solennellement
qu'il n'y aurait pas de rattrapage des
prix pourtant une nouvelle hausse de 10
% sera bien appliquée au tar de
l'électricité le 1er février 2024 la 4e
hausse depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel
Macron plus 45% en 2 ans du jamais vu en
moyenne ce sera plus 18 € par mois pour
une famille qui se chauffe à
l'électricité plus 116 € par mois pour
nos boulangers déjà asphyxiés et combien
de milliers d'euros ajoutés à la
détresse de nos agriculteurs les
Français sont condamnés à rembourser
l'argent que vous avez distribué pendant
les élections alors que 30 pour d'entre
eux ont froid chez eux ou renoncent à se
chauffer correctement par manque
d'argent cela monte même à 50 % chez les
Français vivants dans nos campagnes vous
devriez avoir honte de ces résultats
après 7 ans au pouvoir malgré toutes vos
excuses et tous vos mensonges ces sont
bien le fruit de choix énergétique
ératique de votre gouvernement et de
votre choix de rétablir une taxe alors
que le prix de l'électricité baisse sur
les marchés le RN réitère ses
propositions baisse de la TVA de 20 à 5
sur toutes les énergies libérer la
France des règles absurdes du marché
européen de l'électricité investir
massivement dans la recherche et le
nucléaire énergie la moins chère et la
moins polluante monsieur le ministre la
première décision du nouveau
gouvernement a donc été d'affaiblir un
peu plus le pouvoir d'achat des Français
jusqu'à quel sommet Atal le taxeur et le
maire le menteur vont-ils continuer à
faire exploser les factures des
Français la parole est à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire ministre de l'économie des
finan de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Député
pffer vous êtes un peu pingre avec les
Français votre proposition de baisse la
TVA sur éctricité de 205,5 % ça
représente une économie de l'ordre de
300 € par an pour les ménages là où nous
nous avons pris en charge la moitié de
la facture jusqu'à 1000 € pour les M
nous avons fait trois fois mieux nous
sommes trois fois plus généreux que vous
pour défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
Français vous nous parlez de nucléaire
vous nous parlez de population précaire
vous nous parlez d'énergie renouvelable
mais qu'est-ce qui va financer les
énergies renouvelables le nucléaire et
la protection des plus précaires sinon
la taxe intérieure c'est la consommation
finale d'électricité qui est là pour
financer l'avenir de l'électricité Fran
la souveraineté et l'indépendance de la
nation en matière de produ électrique je
crois que le rassemblement national
était attaché à l'indépendance et la
souveraineté française je m'aperçois que
ce n'est pas le cas mais dans le fond
cet exemple la taxe intérieure sur la
consommation finale d'électricité elle
montre assez bien l'irresponsabilité
totale du rassemblement national elle
montre assez bien ce que vous êtes comme
formation
politique vous n'avez aucune solution
passé vous n'avez que des critiques pour
le présent et vous n'avez aucune
proposition pour l'avenir voilà qui
résume bien le rassemblement
national je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre avec vous ce
qui est bien c'est que c'est toujours la
faute des autres jamais de la vôtre qui
a abandonné nos centrales nucléaires et
hydrauliques face aux pressions des
écologistes et de l'Union européenne
c'est vous qui a fermé FIM c'est vous
qui a subventionné les éoliennes nous
rendant dépendant au gaz russes de
Monsieur Poutine c'est vous alors vous
faites les mauvais choix demain nous
ferons les bons et les Français nous
font confiance merci beaucoup monsieur
le
ministre qui a dit monsieur le député
que l'énergie nucléaire était
extrêmement dangereuse et qu'il fallait
en sortir Marine Le Pen la présidente du
rassemblement
national la parole est à Monsieur
davidib merci merci madame la Présidente
je veux je veux moi aussi dire ma grande
émotion après ce qui s'est passé à
Pamier ce matin je n'évoquerai pas les
questions agricoles mais j'évoquerai
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie un
dossier qui pourrait relever de ce que
les agriculteurs ont dénoncé comme on
marche sur la tête le barne attend en
effet que l'État se positionne sur un
projet bien avancé d'injection de CO2
dans le bassin de lac ce projet appelé
Picasso et porté par les groupes
français Terga et Lafarge espagnol
Repsol et mital Kadi tous les
industriels présents à lac toutes les
organisations syndicales tous les élus
tous les députés berné sont contre
j'avais fait de cette opposition à
Roland lescur
la l'idée l'expression et je veux ici
saluer d'ailleurs l'écoute et la
disponibilité qui a été la sienne
aujourd'hui c'est à l'état de nous dire
ce qui veut j'explique les enjeux 1 il
n'est pas possible d'injecter et
d'extraire concomitamment dans une même
cavité en géologie le en même temps ça
ne marche pas 2 depuis 2010 à
l'initiative des industriel des
syndicats des collectivités locales l'AC
a changé son logiciel le gaz extrait
reste à l'AC pour être cédé aux seuls
industriels présents à un tarif
compétitif nous avons ainsi réussi la
mutation d're bassin industriel par
ailleurs de par la très forte honneur en
souffre notre gaz nous avons obtenu une
dérogation à la loi Hulo l'activité de
la biochimie la chimie du soufre c'est
1500 salariés 3 le projet Picasso
mettrait un terme à cette activité
Picasso c'est 80 emplois la tyochimie
c'est 1500 emplois 1500 d'un côté 80 de
l'autre alors l'injection n'est pas à
rejeter en soi mais l'AC ne saurait être
sacrifié pour des groupe qui redoute la
taxe européenne de 2026 aussi au-delà
des aspects environnementaux et d'image
importer du CO2 je souhaite connaître
nous souhaitons connaître la position de
l'État sur cette question merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno LEM ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Député Habib vous connaissez notre
ambition c'est de faire de la France la
première nation décarboné en Europe à
horizon 2040 et pour ça nous voulons
étudier toutes les solutions y compris
le stockage géologique de CO2 donc nous
sommes tout à fait ouverts à cette
possibilité là sur le site de lac c'est
à peu près 500 millions de tonnes de CO2
qui pourrait être stocké pour certaines
activités comme la production de ciment
si on veut décarboner il n'y a pas
d'autre solution pour le moment que de
stocker le carbone donc je le redis nous
sommes ouvert à cette option là pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas été saisis
d'une demande formelle sur le projet
Picasso donc nous attend d'avoir la
saisine formelle et ensuite la décision
de l'État elle sera rendue en fonction
de trois critères premier critère
l'acceptabilité de la population et je
le dis comme Ministre en charge
désormais de l'énergie il faut que sur
tous les projets énergétiques la
population soit convaincue et accepte
les projets qui ont toujours des
incidences locales qui sont importantes
deuxième condition le respect de nos
critères environnementaux enfin trè
condition la défense de l'emploi
industriel il ne s'agit pas en créant du
stockage géologique de CO2 on détruise
d'autres emplois industriels sur le site
à ces trois conditions là Monsieur le
Député Habib nous sommes ouvert à ces
propositions de stockage de
CO merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole
est à Monsieur paulier pour le groupe la
France insoumise merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Premier Ministre
la ministre de l'école privé étant en
situation de conflit d'intérêt je vous
adresse ma question
directementer journal méiaap part
révélait le rapport caché de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale concernant le collège
Stanislas l'établissement sous contrat
avec l'État financé sur fonds public ne
respecte pas la liberté de conscience
des élèves il y règne un climat
homophobe et une culture du viol qui les
mettent en danger les programmes
scolaires n'y sont pas entièrement
dispensé manifestement le collège
Stanislas est un territoire perdu de la
République où la loi ne s'applique pas
on y croit et on y pratique le
séparatisme le directeur de Stanislas
affirme ainsi obéir je le cite à une
double légitimité faisant prévaloir
celle de l'Église catholique sur celle
de la République son établissement a mis
en place un système de contournement de
la règle commune permettant à une
poignée de ses élèves bien NIS
d'échapper à parcours su monsieur le
premier ministre en décembre dernier
obéissant à la consigne du gouvernement
le préfet du Nord prononçait la rupture
du contrat d'association entre le lycée
AV et l'État au prétexte d'enseignement
contraire aux valeurs de la République
en toute logique sur la base des mêmes
grifs le collège Stanislas devrait à son
tour voir son contrat d'association
rompu dans le cas contraire
chacun constaterait qu'enfant de
puissant vous êtes protégés qu'enfant de
misérable vous êtes maltraité que la
sévérité frappe le lycée musulmans quand
le silence protège le collège catholique
Monsieur le Premier Ministre sommes-nous
en république la loi est-elle la même
pour tous quand allez-vous casser le
contrat d'association avec le collège
séparatiste
Stanislas merci beaucoup la parole est à
madameis porte-parole de gouvernement et
ministre en charge renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député vanagier suite à
l'envoi du rapport effectivement
concernant l'établissement Stanislas le
2 août 2023 plusieurs recommandations
ont été émises et immédiatement des
actions ont été mises en place par
Gabriel hatal qui était alors ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse le rapport a été transmis aux
autorités compétentes des des échanges
ont eu lieu entre le rectorat et le
directeur diocé1 en septembre et en
janvier dernier plus précisément sur le
parent d'élèves qui aurait assuré des
séances de catéchèse à titre bénévole et
qui aurait tenu des propos inappropriés
susceptibles d'être qualifié pénalement
en raison de leur caractère homophobe
oui Gabriel Atal alors ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
a déclenché immédiatement un article 40
pour ce qui est de parcours sup les
recommandations ont éé suivi des fait
puisqueeffectivement des vérifications
et des investigations ont été menées et
les rappels ont été adressés aux
personnes concernées le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et également la
ministre en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur sont en alerte sur ce sujet
mais plus rapidement vous parlez
effectivement de valeur républicaine de
cette capacité à faire République je
vous le dis en réalité votre sujet ce
n'est pas Stanislas c'est que vous
n'aimez pas vous n'aimez pas dans sa
globalité l'école privée vous n'aimez
pas ces françaises et français qui ont
choisi de mettre leurs enfants dans
l'école privée vous êtes en train ici de
faire une différence entre tous les
enfants ceux qui sont en école publique
et en école privée alors qu'ensemble ici
nous devrions être unis pour travailler
à l'excellence pour nos enfants et pour
notre République mais par ailleurs vous
nous donnez des grandes leçons de
républicain appelez peut-être à
commencer par les appliquer c'est-à-dire
vous porter une écharpe appelez à
respecter les règles que vous appelez à
faire voter
ici je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe Juvin
pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicain madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la Santé au mois de juillet ici nous
avions alerté votre prédécesseur madame
la ministre car 20000 médecins à diplôme
étranger hor Union européenne les Pasu
concourrait pour exercer la médecine en
France votre administration alors avait
décrété qu'on prendrait seulement 2700
candidats sur 20000 pourquoi 2700
personne n'a jamais compris on a besoin
de médecin et avouz que en limiter aussi
arbitrairement le nombre c'est assez
absurde alors nous vous avions dit n'en
prenez pas 2700 mais prenez tout ceux
qui ont le niveau bref faites un examen
pas un concours monsieur Brown a ignoré
notre proposition le concours a eu lieu
et puis la catastrophe annoncée n'a pas
tardé donc vous avez dû prendre hier
dans la précipitation des mesures de
rustine qui ne règle rien au fond car le
concours des Pasu reste totalement
inadapté alors je repose ma question
madame la ministre comme je l'ai posé à
Monsieur Brown allez-vous transformer le
concours de Padu en examen afin
d'admettre tous les médecins qui ont le
niveau et les affecés là où on en a
besoin bravo je vous remercie monsieur
le député la parole est à Madame
Catherine vurin ministre du Travail de
la santé et des
solidarités merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Philippe Juvin
monsieur le député vous l'avez dit
effectivement il y a ce sujet de ces
praticiens qui aujourd'hui travaillent
dans notre système de soins et dont
évidemment la présence est tout à fait
importante c'est la raison pour laquelle
conformément à ce qu'a dit monsieur le
Président de la République le 16 janvier
dernier il était important de répondre
aux attentes de celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui travaillent dans nos
hôpitaux c'est le sens du décret qui est
sorti hier et qui répond effectivement à
cette évaluation des compétences de 2023
et qui a permis de clarifier la
situation de 2700 praticiens la
situation pour eux est la suivante
lorsqu'ils ont validé cet examen et
qu'ils sont en poste dans notre pays ils
peuvent rester là où ils le sont
nombreux sont d'ailleurs les députés qui
depuis que je suis au gouvernement m'ont
alerté sur la nécessité qu'il y avait de
trouver des réponsse pour celles et ceux
qui apportaient des réponses en matière
de santé le deuxième sujet est celui qui
sont aujourd'hui en dehors de notre pays
mais qui ont validé ce diplôme et qui
donc d'ici la fin du prier trimestre
seront en capacité de venir exercer dans
notre pays le troisième sujet c'est
celui de ceux celles et ceux qui quelque
part ont raté cette examen et pour
lesquels il y a une capacité à
retravailler d'ici 2024 donc derrière
votre question il reste deux sujets le
premier c'est effectivement la situation
de celles et ceux qui sont là jusqu'en
2024 la de de c'est celle de la
validation dans tous les cas c'est une
réponse concrète pour 2700 d'entre eux
et je ne doute pas que nos concitoyens
qui attendent des médecins de proximité
ont déjà une part de réponse je vous
remercie madame la ministre monsieur le
député oui madame la ministre vous
n'avez pas répondu à la question que je
vous posais sur la transformation du
concours en examen bon pour augmenter le
nombre de médecins doubler le numérus
closus abolissez l'oral de la fin de
première année garantissez le SMIC aux
externes encourageer le cumul emploir
retraite des médecins et tout les
mesures que nous avons voté dans la
proposition de loi de l'excellent
collègue ner mais nos propositions c'est
toujours pareil madame la ministre soit
vous les ignorez soit vous les
confisquez sans dire que ça vient de
chez nous c'est la stratégie du coucou
vous savez cet oiseau qui prend le nid
de l'autre et encore pour bacler
l'application alors cette affaire n'est
pas du madame la ministre elle elle
révèle une question de méthode vous
n'écoutez jamais les propositions des
oppositions acceptez cette idée
extravagante d'aut que vous puisse avoir
des idées intelligentes nous comptons
sur vous ne soyez pas la ministre d'un
seul camp soyez la ministre qui écoute
le Parlement madame la ministre tout le
Parlement et pas seulement vos amis
merci beaucoup mon ch cèg madame la
[Applaudissements]
ministre vous le savez le drame de notre
pays c'est le manque de médecin
l'origine vous la connaissez comme moi
c'est le numérus closus le gouvernement
qui a le courage venir vers le numérus
aperus c'est celui-là travaillons
ensemble pour
avancer je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Lisiane
metteyer pour le groupe
Renaissance prés monsieur le Premier
ministre depuis hier les bateaux de la
pêche de la façade atlantique sont àa en
application de la décision du Conseil
d'État d'interdire la pêche dans le golf
de Gascogne pendant 1 mois cette
décision fait suite a une saisine de
quatre associations environnementales
visant à réduire les captures
accidentelles de petit cacé cette
interdiction est un véritable coup de
Massu porté à nos pêcheurs qui avaient
engagé de lourds investissements
conformément au plan d'action entre le
gouvernement et les professionnels en
faveur d'une pêche plus responsable H4
caméras dispositif d'efarouchement et
cetera j'étais au côté des pêcheurs
artisans l'orienté de ma circonscription
dès le 26 décembre mes collègues
Stéphane bûchou dédié Leal lilianangu et
bien d'autres sont également mobilisés
la décision du Conseil d'État vient
anéantir tous les efforts entrepris et
ce alors même que la filière souffre
depuis de nombreuses années d'un
contexte de crise successive brexit
hausse du gasoil conséquente de la
guerre en Ukraine s'ils ont toujours
fait face et continuent de le faire
cette dernière décision remet cependant
en cause leur savoir-faire séculaire en
opposant écologie et économie alors même
que nous leur devons notre souveraineté
alimentaire et que ces objectifs doivent
être complémenta avec cette décision ce
sont plus de 450 navires de pêche
impactés dans le golf le Gascogne mais
c'est l'ensemble de la filière de la de
pêche de la façade atlantique qui est
menacé rien que ce sur ma
circonscription de l'Orient ce sont 3000
emplois concernés Monsieur le Premier
Ministre comment rassurer nos pêcheurs
comment les accompagner dans cette
nouvelle crise de tout temps ils ont
fait preuve d'un savoir remarquable
indispensable à notre économie nous leur
devons notre soutien et alors que
l'année 2024 est celle de la mer ne
devons-nous pas réarmer notre filière
pêche et faire de la France cette
puissance nation maritime c'est l'élu
qui vous parle mais aussi la fille et
petite fille de marin pêcheur groisillon
qui a à cœur de sauver la filière
pêche je vous remercie madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
mteer quand on parle de souveraineté
alimentaire de la France et de Rich pour
notre pays évidemment que la pêche a une
place absolument majeure dans notre
souveraineté et dans ce dont nous
pouvons être fier à l'international nous
avons une filière pêche puissante de
très grande qualité une très grande
expertise et surtout passionné par son
métier et à l'occasion des Assises de
l'économie de la mer au mois de décembre
dernier le président de la République
lui-même s'est engagé sur des mesures
fortes un nouveau contrat stratégique de
de filières pour renouveler les flottes
on s'est engagé sur 750 millions d'euros
dans les années à venir pour renouveler
les flottes pour renforcer
l'attractivité de ces métier et notre
compétitivité ensuite je veux rappeler
madame la députée que ce gouvernement et
cette majorité ont été au côté de nos
pêcheurs dans toutes les tempêtes des
dernières années au moment du brexit au
moment du covid au moment des crises
liées à l'inflation des prix de
l'énergie après la guerre en Ukraine au
global c'est 305 50 million d'euros qui
ont été engagés pour soutenir la filière
pêche à l'occasion de ces crises et vous
me permettrez de rendre hommage au
travail d'Hervé Berville qui au
gouvernement était particulièrement
mobilisé évidemment en sa qualité de
secrétaire d'État à la
mer vous l'avez
dit après la décision du Conseil d'État
c'est une nouvelle tempête qu'affronte
nos pêcheurs
oui nous serons à leur côté nous avons
annoncé d'ors et déjà un certain nombre
de mesures pour les soutenir d'abord une
mesure d'équité et de cohérence la
décision du Conseil d'État ne
s'appliquait qu'au navires français nous
l'avons étendu au navir étrangers et je
le dis nous le ferons respectter les
navires étrangers ne pourront pas venir
pêcher là où les navires français ne
peuvent pas pêcher du fait de cette
décision 2uxè mesure des indemnisations
importantes pour la filière les mesures
notifiées à la Commission européenne
prévoient une indemnisation de 80 à 85 %
du chiffre d'affaires pour les pêcheurs
un soutien à la filière avale pour le
marayage avec 75 % de la perte
d'excédents brut d'exploitation la
possibilité de recourir au chômage
partiel pour les ports les criers et les
marilleurs et enfin pour soutenir la
trésorerie nous ferons en sorte que les
dossiers de demande d'aide soient
traités rapidement et nous mobiliserons
le secteur bancaire mais je le dis
madame la députée j'en suis conscient
nos pêcheurs comme nos agriculteurs
d'ailleurs ils font partie de tous ces
Français qui ont pas envie de survivre
avec des aides ils veulent vivre de leur
travail oui on est au rendez-vous pour
les accompagner pendant ces coups durs
pour les soutenir financièrement mais il
se lèv pas le matin en allant chercher
les aides il se lèvent le matin pour
travailler pour leurs passion et donc ce
que nous devons c'est évidemment faire
en sorte qu'aussi vite que possible ils
puissent à nouveau prendre leur navire
prendre la mer pour aller faire leur
travail faire leur passion et nous
serons à leur côté pour les
accompagner merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Premier Ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Nicolas maisonet pour le
rassemblement national merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse par
défaut à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire puisque à ce jour nous
n'avons ni ministre ni même secrétaire
d'État chargé de la mer monsieur le
ministre à l'agonie de nos agriculteurs
est en train de répondre celle de nos
pêcheurs 450 navires dans les eaux du
golfe de Gascogne resteront taqués
durant un mois interdit d'exercer leur
activité une victoire obtenu par des
associations dites écolo surtout
anti-pêche qui qualifi les chalutiers
d'abattoir flottant rester à quai voilà
la hantise de nos marins français
persécuté par la multiplication des
normes et des politiques iniqu de
l'Union européenne que vous soutenez au
nom de l'écologie punitive et de la
décroissance c'est toute une filière qui
est en train d'être assassinée dans ma
circonscription au gros du roi 2e port
de Méditerranée le nombre de salalutiers
a chuté de 35 à 15 en l'espace de 30 ans
sur cette même période la flotte de
pêche française a perdu la moitié de ses
navires au motif de vouloir préser la
ressource aliotique la France pourtant
doté de trois façades maritimes
exceptionnelles et de la deuxième zone
économique exclusive du monde importe
désormais 2/ers de ces produits de la
mer quelle hypocrisie les Tau resserent
sur ceux qui ont consacré leur vie à
l'un des métiers les plus importants qui
soit celui de nourrir la population
essentiel à notre souveraineté
alimentaire exerçant dans des conditions
parfois extrêmement difficile il se voit
dicter une politique commune à Bruxelles
totalement déconnecté des spécificités
du modèle français système de quôa
hasard 2 concurrence déloyale réduction
du nombre de jours de sortie en mer
développement anarchique de l'éolien
offshore explosion des coups du gasoile
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir passez-moi l'expression quitter
le navire alors la colère monte monsieur
le monsieur le ministre et elle est
légitime allez-vous donc laisser notre
filière de pêche française
disparaître je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
maisonnis monsieur le député vous pouvez
utiliser tous les mots que vous voulez
charger l'Union européenne de tous les
mots que vous voulez la réalité c'est
que l'événement qui a le plus mis en
danger nos pêcheurs ces dernières années
c'est le brexit et que les premiers
soutiens du brexit c'était vous c'était
le rassemblement national
il y a même dans les quelques communes
dans les quelques communes que vous
dirigez que dirigent des élus du
rassemblement national des rues du
brexit qui ont été inaugurées par les
élus du rassemblement national c'est
dire à quel point vous soutenez ça oui
c'était la plus grande mise en danger de
nos pêcheurs et si nous sommes parvenus
par un accord à sauver no nos pêcheurs
dans le cadre du brexit en les
protégeant en leur permettant de
travailler c'est certainement pas grâce
à vous c'est grâce à tout le travail qui
a été engagé par la majorité le
gouvernement Michel Barnier à l'époque
qui s'est mobilisé aussi sur le sujet et
la réalité c'est que vous parlez des
risques pour nos pêcheurs mais à aucun
moment quand ils ont fait l'objet de
grandes difficultés notamment sur le
prix du carburant sur ces sujets liés au
brexit ni au Parlement européen ni ici
on a entendu les élus du rassemblement
national aller les défendre
non à cinq reprises on a prolongé un
dispositif de soutien aux pêcheurs pour
leurs carburant 80 millions d'euros qui
ont été investis on ne vous a pas
entendu à à l'époque les défendre et le
réclamer donc oui ils font face
aujourd'hui à une très grande angoisse
et une très grande inquiétude liée à
cette décision qui les empêche de sortir
dans le golfe de de Gascogne pour 450
navires du fait de la capture de cet acé
on est au rendez-vous comme on l'a
toujours été dans toutes les tempêtes
pour les accompagner avec un soutien que
je rappelais il y a un instant en
matière d'indemnisation mais je suis
parfaitement conscient que ce qu'ils
attendent encore une fois c'est pas des
aides c'est de pouvoir travailler et
évidemment le cœur de notre mobilisation
c'est de leur permettre de reprendre la
mer aussi vite que
possible je vous remercie monsieur le
Premier
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe F pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
plus de 2 mois et demi après les
premières inondations dans le Pas de
calis de nombreux concitoyens sont
encore les pieds dans l'eau de nombreux
résidents ont perdu leur maison et les
solutions de relogement ne sont pas
toujours adaptées de nombreuses
entreprises peinent à retrouver leur
activité où sont définit perdu de
nombreux habitants commerçants artisans
sont encore en attente d'une prise en
charge par leur assurance nos
agriculteurs vivent des moments
particulièrement difficile alors que
l'hiver sera encore long sans véritable
solution pour assurer la reprise du
travail sur le terrain au quotidien je
partage leur désarois un quotidien
marqué également par des nombreuses
visites ministérielles et je veux
remercier ici les différents membres du
gouvernement qui ont pris la mesure de
la situation comme vous monsieur le
Premier ministre pour votre premier
déplacement le jour même de votre
nomination de nombreuses annonces é
formulé des solutions d'urgence sont
travaillé pourtant nous sommes encore
loin du bout du tunnel trop de sujets
restent en suspens et la détresse a fait
place à la colère mais aujourd'hui nous
devons faire face en ayant foi en la
résilience la solidarité et la ténacité
des habitants du pas decalé à ce titre
il me le disait encore ce dimanche lors
d'une réunion à Montreuil surmer il
souhaite s'engager participer donner
leur avis sur l'avenir de leur
territoire ils ne veulent pas seulement
être victime de ce cataclysme mais être
pleinement acteur pour que cela ne se
reproduise plus ici comme ailleurs les
élus locaux dont je salue l'action
exemplaire et dévoué veulent également
pouvoir agir mais avec les mains libres
fort de leur expérience et leur
connaissance F du territoire tout cela
ne pourra se faire qu'à hauteur d'hommes
au sein de comités locaux regroupant les
citoyens les élus et tous les organismes
concernés les habitants connaissent leur
territoire les élus locaux connaissent
leur territoire faisons leur confiance
libérons les énergies simplifions encore
et toujours les dé administrative qui
entrave beaucoup trop notre action
collective face face à cette catastrophe
hors norme c'est un appel de détresse
que je lance Monsieur le Premier
Ministre pouvez-vous nous rappeler les
actions engagées par le gouvernement et
que comp-il faire pour l'après merci
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Prisc porte-parole
du gouvernement et ministre en charge du
renouveau
démocratique merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député je vous remercie de
votre question qui rappelle encore une
fois l'importance de continuer à nous
mobiliser à ne surtout pas oublier ces
habitantes et ces habitants qui ont été
durement touchés comme vous l'avez
justement rappelé ils font preuve d'une
résilience et d'une tenacité remarquable
et je sais que une fois retourné sur vos
terre vous pourrez leur faire part de
ses paroles le ministre de la transition
écologique qui me demande de le
représenter aujourd'hui est en ce moment
même justement à leur côté pour tenir le
premier comité ministériel de suiv
de la situation des sinistrés cette
réunion sera l'occasion de faire donc le
suivi et de répondre aux attentes fortes
et légitimes des habitants et des élus
locaux concernant aussi bien la
simplification des procédures que le
financement de la lutte contre les
inondations s'agissant du financement le
président de la République a assuré le
soutien plein et entier des habitants
durement touchés et en fond de soutien
de 50 millions d'euros a été
immédiatement déployé le Premier
ministre en a précisé les contours
l'heure effectivement de son premier
déplacement en tant que Premier ministre
c'était le 9 janvier dernier ce fond de
50 millions d'euros s'ajoute au moyens
déjà engagés par l'État et sur le
versement des aides précisément 93 % des
sinistrés ont déjà bénéficié d'une
expertise et 15000 à comptes ont déjà
été versés par les assureurs le
gouvernement étudia également des
mécanismes supplémentaires pour répondre
plus précisément aux besoins des
artisans et des commerçants vous l'avez
également souligné 2 281 commune ont
d'ors et déjà fait l'objet d'une
reconnaissance de l'État en catastrophe
naturelle un deuxième décret viendra en
fin de semaine pour actualiser ce
premier décret par ailleurs oui le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé en
premier lieu et en premier chef duquel
le Premier ministre lui-même qui chaque
semaine s'assure que l'ensemble des
actions engagées soient bien mises en
place et comme il s'yté engagé le 9
janvier dernier il se rendra à nouveau
sur ces territoires sinistré début
février je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur René Pilato pour le groupe la
France inst mer madame la présidente
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie
Monsieur le
Maire vous promettiez une augmentation
du prix de l'électricité inférieure à 10
% parole tenue vous assinez 9,8 chers
pauvres vous avez sauté sans repas en
2023 grâce à la bienveillance de Bery
vous en sonrez 109,8 au lieu de 110 en
2024 mon bon prince les pauvres vous
remercient en charante des parents
isolés très souvent des mamans doivent
choisir entre payer la facture
d'électricité ou payer la cantine Infiné
les gosses ne mangent plus à leur faim
d'après vous vivent la concurrence qui
fait baisser les prix ils n'ont jamais
été aussi haut et ce n'est pas fini des
prix de vente basés sur une centrale au
gaz et totalement déconnecté des prix de
production mais qui permettent de gaver
les énergéticiens européens comme jamais
vos sont-il au courant que l'explosion
des prix de l'énergie la mine les forces
vives du pays Monsieur le Maire quelque
chose en France ne tourne pas rond la
sortie des tarifs réglementés c'est vous
les boulangeries qui ferment c'est vous
les TPE PME en difficulté c'est encore
vous les communes qui rognent sur le
social c'est toujours vous l'explosion
de la pauvreté dans ce pays ça se sait
que c'est vous jusqu'où allez-vous
affamer et tondre la population
pour que les Bernard Arnaud béancour
mulèz et pouillanet les 43 milliardaires
qui ont doublé leur fortune en 10 ans
soit protégé renoncer à cette hausse de
10 % du prix de l'électricité est une
décision politique celle d'être au
service du peuple et non de quelquesuns
ma question est simple allez-vous
renoncer à votre hausse d'impôt et
trouver l'argent ailleurs en taxant les
super profits des énergéticiens par
exemple je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le député la
parole est à Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député Pilatos qui
décidément ne tourne pas rond en France
c'est la
nupes quelle
incohérence dans vos propos vous nous
dites qu'il faut protéger le pouvoir
d'achat de nos compatriot contre la
flambée des prix d'électricité je ne
peux pas être plus d'accord mais dans ce
CASL il y avait un instrument
qui s'appelle le bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité que aucun autre européen
n'a mis en place qui a représenté au
total 44 milliards d'euros de dépenses
publiqu pour protéger tous les Français
contre l'explosion des prix
deélectricité vous avez voté
contre pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat
de nos compatriotes monsieur le député
il fallait revaloriser lesliminat
sociaux et les indexer sur l'inflation
vous avez voté contre pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de nos compatriotes il
fallait Rev des retraites notamment les
retraites minimales nous l'avons fait
vous avez voté contre pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat de ceux qui travaille il
fallait indexer le barê de l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'inflation nous l'avons
fait vous avez voté contre tous ce qui
protèg le pouvoir d'achat des Français
vous avez voté contre en revanche vous
avez proposé de supprimer de supprimer
la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaire qui elle rapporte des
centaines d'euros aux ouvriers aux
salariés aux employés qui décident de
travailler davantage dans le fond votre
conception de la France elle est très
simple c'est toujours plus de taxes
toujours plus d'impôts toujours plus de
redistribution mais toujours point de
rémunération du travail et toujours
moins de récompense pour ceux qui
travaillent nous avons exactement la
vision inverse nous nous récompensons
ceux qui travaillent ceux qui ont un
emploi ceux qui sont salariés et ceux
qui font vivre la
nation merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député monsieur le
ministre tout simplement votretique
qu'il y a un ti des Français qui pas je
vous remcie la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue